well the u.s. is not planning new
sanctions against Russia after releasing
a list of prominent Russians said to
have close ties to President Putin the
Treasury Department revealed the names
last night under a law meant to punish
Russia for US election meddling more
than 200 officials and wealthy
businessmen are named Elizabeth Palmer's
in Moscow outside the Kremlin where
Putin calls a list a hostile step
Elizabeth good morning good morning
President Putin has now reacted to the
list he says it complicates the US
Russia ties and then he joked that he
personally was a little offended not to
be on it
seriously though there are a lot of
high-powered Russians who are relieved
this morning some of them in the offices
in the Kremlin behind me they thought
this list might expose embarrassing
details either of their political
affiliations or of their vast wealth but
it does neither it's just really a list
of names and job titles it includes
obvious Putin allies like the Foreign
Minister Sergey Lavrov and business
heavyweights like Herman Graf the head
of Russia's biggest bank and Oleg
Deripaska the former business partner of
Paul Manafort president Trump's ex
campaign manager but there's no singling
out of people who are especially close
to Putin or especially corrupt the US
Treasury spells out that being on the
list does not mean that sanctions will
necessarily follow so the question
everybody here is asking is what exactly
is it for John I lives at Elizabeth
Palmer in Moscow thanks you know the
White House says that they don't need to
implement sanctions because Moscow is
being deterred but as you know the CIA
director said Moscow is still
interfering in bryn American elections
so they don't they're not really being
deterred well what the CIA director also
told me is they're not being helpful on
North Korea right they're not being
helpful on a number of other fronts so
so we'll see if Congress now makes the
White House follow up on this sanctions
bill that was voted for overwhelmingly
by members of both parties